herren herzlich willkommen zur
pressekonferenz nach der
kabinettssitzung der bayerische
ministerrat hat sich heute intensiv mit
den weiteren fahrplan in sachen corona
pandemie beschäftigt über die ergebnisse
informieren sie ministerpräsident dr
markus söder wirtschaftsminister hubert
aiwanger sozialministerium carolina
trautner kultusminister michael piazolo
im gesundheitsministerium melanie huml
jetzt beginnt der ministerpräsident
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wir wollen ihnen heute den bayern plan
für corona für den nächsten monat und
bis pfingsten vorstellen
dabei ist folgende prinzipien wichtig
wir lassen nach wie vor vorsicht an
oberster stelle walten
wir machen alles schrittweise wir machen
es nicht überstürzt in stufen mit hohen
sicherheitsauflagen und später als
andere
warum heute warum haben wir heute diesen
fahrplan ermittelt nun zum einen weil
wir die beschlüsse der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz von letzter
woche nachvollziehen mussten und
rechtlich umsetzen mussten zum zweiten
aber weil es hier sehr viele
unterschiedliche anzahl jetzt gibt
ansätze gibt wie wir mit der pandemie
bekämpfung mit corona in der nächsten
wochen gehen wollten die heute ein
angebot machen ein angebot nicht nur für
bayern so noch für morgen ein modell wie
der vorsichtige weg aussehen kann
es gibt bundesländer liegen einen sehr
schnellen weg keine kritik aber wir
wollen einen vorsichtigen weg gehen und
für alle die diesen vorsichtigen weg
mitgehen wollen könnt ihr das vielleicht
auch eine blaupause sein besonnenheit
ist an der stelle trumpf sieht einklang
und im gleichklang mit den umsichtigen
und das was ich jetzt vorstelle ist auch
mit der bundeskanzlerin gesprochen und
mit baden-württemberg ähnlich abgestimmt
worden
da denken wir in ähnlicher form was ist
der weg wir werden schrittweise ganz
vorsichtig öffnen zeitlich später als
andere und mit einem konzept und kein
stückwerk
warum ist die zeit jetzt richtig weil
die erfolge eindeutig sichtbar waren
biologen experten unser landesamt für
gesundheit hat uns gesagt
jetzt ist der richtige zeitpunkt für ein
vorsichtiges öffnen
warum denn die erfolge sind eindeutig
der bayerische weg war richtig der
bayerische weg war richtig wir haben
damit in den letzten wochen und monaten
bayern gut beschützt und vielleicht
sogar einen beitrag dazu gebracht die
waren ja mit am stärksten betroffen euch
das infektionsgeschehen an der nähe zu
österreich vielleicht haben wir einen
beitrag dazu erbracht deutschland ein
stück zu helfen
entscheidungsgrundlagen sind die zahlen
und nur die sind für uns relevant wir
hatten zu beginn ein explosionsartiges
infektionsgeschehen jetzt ist corona
unter kontrolle
wir hatten zu beginn wachstumsfragen
täglich von 30 prozent jetzt heute
aktuelle stand 0,4 prozent wir hatten
einen reproduktions faktor der lag so
dass einer 6 angesteckt hat jetzt liegt
er nach rk ii berechnung bei 0,7 und
nach unserem landesamt für gesundheit
sogar noch ein bisschen weniger aber
beziehungs nerv des rk aktuell in bayern
wenn mir fragt wer ist im moment
infiziert im moment dann ist abgezogen
von denen die schon wieder genesen sind
zum glück und denen die leider
verstorben sind haben wir um die 6400
aktuelle moment infizierte in ganz
bayern sind etwas von 0,05 prozent diese
bisherigen zahlen die zum heutigen tag
sind lassen den mut zu vorsichtige
schritte der öffnung zu gehen
allein in der letzten woche allein der
letzten woche haben wir die zahl der
infizierten insgesamt halbiert das alles
sind positive entwicklungen die uns mut
geben aber auch die vernunft mit guten
gewissen veränderungen vornehmen zu
können
parallel kann man sagen haben wir das
gesundheitssystem hochgefahren und
fahren ist weiter hoch nur zwei zahlen
dieses verdeutlichen sollen wir haben
die zahl der intensivbetten mit beatmung
seit beginn der krise um 31 prozent
erhöht alle notfallpläne stehen egal ob
und wann eine zweite welle kommt unser
bayerisches gesundheitssystem ist dafür
gerüstet und wir bauen weiter auf das
heißt
selbst wenn die welle abflacht selbst
wenn es weniger gibt werden wir diesen
teil deutlich ausbauen so dass wir für
alle eventualitäten der welt gerüstet
sind und das große thema der schutz
materialien allein in den letzten wochen
haben wir 50 millionen masken aus bayern
in bayern ausgeliefert oder sind noch
jetzt bei uns in den lagern daher wenn
man die zahlen zusammen fast kann man
zum einen sagen dass die strategie
richtig war
zeitpunkt und umfang waren richtig es
war angemessen und verhältnismäßig es
hat die überwiegende zahl der gerichte
auch bestätigt aber wir müssen eingriffe
in freiheit und zwar fundamentale
abwägen
wir müssen auch den weg finden wie wir
nicht nur in die krise hinein gekommen
sind wie wir sie durchgeführt haben
sondern wie wir auch diese krise wieder
herauskommen
das ist ganz entscheidend wir wollen
dabei nicht zu überstürzen
lieber langsam und sicherer
der schutz der gesundheit ist zu uns
nach wie vor oberstes gebot von der
schutz der älteren der risikogruppen ist
wichtig aber wohl auch die lebensfreude
und die freiheit der vielen jüngeren im
land auch ernst nehmen akzeptieren und
unterstützen also heute ist zeit zum
handeln ein modell das wir anbieten für
den umsichtigen den vorsichtigen weg der
vielleicht für den einen oder anderen
ein gutes angebot sein kann
wir machen wir das wir waren heute
längere zeit achsen definieren damit
perspektiven setzen wir werden es so
machen dass wir auch diese zeitachsen in
einer form von atmender strategie
darstellen was heißt das wir planen
längerfristig und setzten daten
endgültig entschieden wird aber je nach
der infektion schlage das heißt passen
die zahlen bleibt es dabei
verschlechtern sich die zahlen
möglicherweise sogar rapide wird etwas
verschoben oder vielleicht sogar
zurückgefahren
dies ist eine atmende strategie und wir
werden das nicht mehr nur landesweit
machen sondern wir werden jetzt bewusst
regional agieren das heißt es werden
auch in bayern ein sehr
unterschiedliches infektionsgeschehen in
etlichen regionen hat sich sehr positiv
entwickelten
in einigen sind wir noch dabei und haben
wir in den letzten tagen noch einige
höhere infektionszahlen dort reden wir
nochmal ganz bewusst mit den zuständigen
landräten und oberbürgermeistern mit
welchen besonderen pandemieplänen wie
jetzt auch mehr konzentriert was
ressourcen tests material und personal
betrifft ansetzen können also wir machen
im vater vernunft eine öffnung mit
umsicht und glauben dass wir mit guten
gewissen weg gehen können jedenfalls ist
das doch die empfehlung unser monitoring
gruppe und frau breit keßler
unsere experten virologen die uns
beraten und nicht zuletzt was für mich
die amtliche referenz stelle des
landesamtes für gesundheit dass uns das
empfohlen hat ich sage aber auch ganz
ehrlich natürlich bleiben restrisiken
solange kein impfstoff besteht aber
grundrechte dauerhaft einzuschränken
geht nur wenn es angemessen ist
wir glauben dass es jetzt nicht mehr die
form ist es in dieser form weiter zu
machen also mehr freiheit aber auch mehr
verantwortung für den einzelnen und wir
bieten dass jeder mit dieser ein
stückweit stärke gewonnen freiheit
verantwortungsvoll umgeht
der staat bleibt wachsam wie ist der
korona fahrplan im einzelnen ab morgen
bereits also den 6
wandeln wir die ausgangs beschränkung in
eine kontakt beschränkung um das heißt
es ist erlaubt rauszugehen
man braucht nicht mehr zu hause zu
bleiben sondern diese diskussion ist
jetzt ab morgen anders aber 1,5 meter
abstand bleibt distanz gebot bleibt die
eine kontaktperson bleibt wir wollen
keine gruppenbildungen partys oder
ähnliches mehr
aber wir wollen die familie stärken
deswegen ist ab morgen erlaubt neben der
einen kontaktperson kinder geschwister
eltern großeltern also verwandte in
gerader linie zu besuchen und sich mit
ihnen zu treffen zu hause oder auch im
öffentlichen raum also ab morgen eine
kontakt beschränkung distanz gebot
wir prüfen übrigens woche für woche wie
sich das entsprechend weiterentwickelt
familie ist für uns ganz besonders
wichtig deswegen stehen die
erleichterungen für familien und die
sicherheit der familie an oberste stelle
deswegen haben wir uns vor allem heute
beschäftigt mit dem thema senioren
halten und pflegeheime kitas und schulen
das sehen sie hier auch an den
vertretern die heute dazu sind am
schluss kommt noch das thema handel und
gastronomie bis uns aber auch wichtig
ist altenpflegeheime
behinderteneinrichtung krankenhäuser
haben eine besondere priorität was den
schutz betrifft denn ihr waren die
todesfälle am stärksten
wir spüren aber auch die folgen und die
belastung durch isolation
nun müsse man eine richtige balance
finden das ist zum einen wir höhen
weiter die schutzkonzepte für die
mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter in den
entsprechenden einrichtungen durch mehr
schutz material durch serien test oder
einen test und durch entsprechende
schutzausrüstung die getroffen würde auf
der anderen seite wollen wir aber auch
möglich machen zu besuchen wieder zu
sehen und zwar nicht nur zur
sterbebegleitung ganz im gegenteil auch
lebensfreude zu vermitteln
deswegen wird ab kommenden samstag und
sonntag also rechtzeitig zum muttertag
wenn ich das sagen darf ist eine
deutliche erleichterung geben schutz
jahr aber eine leichte es ist besuch
möglich allerdings unter bestimmten
voraussetzungen mit maske mit abstand
halten wenn es geht im freien mit ganz
festen besuchszeiten mit einer maximalen
besuchszahl zeitgleich in den
entsprechenden einrichtungen und
besuchen soll und kann dann entweder die
eine kontaktperson oder ein
entsprechendes familienmitglied
beziehungsweise ins kinder sind daneben
die eltern warum ab samstag und sonntag
warum weil die heime und die
einrichtungen sollen sie noch
vorbereiten können auf die
entsprechenden schutzmaßnahmen die
beiden damen werden sich darum kümmern
dass das entsprechend funktioniert auf
die jeweiligen bereiche kinder
ab morgen werden alle spielplätze in
bayern geöffnet die sind dann ab morgen
geöffnet
und wie geht es mit der kita weiter
die kita ist eine ganz wichtige
einrichtung wie alle kindergärten
schwierige dabei ist der expertenrat ist
nicht einheitlich
es gibt unterschiedliche ansätze was das
infektionsgeschehen betrifft die ein
bewertendes höher die anderen weniger
was ist also die light maßstab vorsicht
vorsicht einerseits haben wir viele
eltern die brauchten die betreuung
wieder stärker andererseits gibt es
eltern die sehr besorgt sind ob seine
ansteckung geben könnte manche kinder
sind froh wenn sie nicht in die kita und
kindergarten müssen ich kriege sogar
briefe gemalte aber umgekehrt möchten
viele kinder auch wieder ihre freunde im
freunde wiedersehen
wir haben bisher ein notfallkonzept das
notfallkonzept war am anfang mit 2
prozent wir haben jetzt aufgebaut auf 10
prozent
unser ziel ist dass bis pfingsten rund
50 prozent der kinder wieder die
möglichkeit haben die entsprechenden
einrichtungen zu besuchen
bis 50 prozent nach pfingsten kommt dann
der andere teil
die schritte jetzt auch dann noch mal
näher erläutert werden ab dem 11 mai ist
der nächste schritt
dort geht es zum einen kinder mit einem
eingliederungs bedarf kinder mit der man
syrischen bedarf also dass die soziale
komponente die wir stärken wollen gerade
auch bei vielen familien ein dringender
wunsch und bedarf besteht aufgrund der
familiensituation und berichten
härtefälle ein wovon man vom beruf
besonders betroffen ist
dazu wird ergänzt die zulassung der
tagespflege einer tagesmutter mit fünf
personen und familien betreuungsgruppen
das sind maximal drei familien die sich
untereinander organisieren können dies
beides zusammen schafft eine große
erleichterung für viele viele familien
und kinder ab dem 25
also dann immer in zwei wochen rhythmen
agieren wir kommen dann die ganzen
vorschulkinder dazu und die
waldkindergärten kommen noch dazu die
vorschulkinder weil die sind diejenigen
die die auch vorbereiten mussten ein
stück weit auf
schuljahr das dann im herbst beginnen
soll
vertraut man wird noch mal sagen welche
gene maßnahmen alles mit entsprechenden
hygienemaßnahmen versehen die sehr
wichtig sind
der vorschlag der von nina graupner kam
orientiert sich sehr stark an den
grundlinien und grundideen der
empfehlung der jugend und familien
oester schule schule ist ähnlich
sensibel wie kita wir haben uns mit der
schulfamilie beraten auch dank an den
kultusminister
wir haben nach einer video-konferenz mit
den lehrerverbänden erhalten und
unzählige eltern haben uns geschrieben
und gerade bei den eltern sind die
sorgen querbeet die einen möchten wieder
schneller schule
andere warnen davor ich glaube alles
können wir sagen wenn wir bei der kita
bis pfingsten ungefähr 50 prozent der
kinder in die kita möglichkeit bringen
wollen geht es für die schule auch wenn
man's lang beraten wenn man überlegt
alle werden aber genau gesehen dass das
in der umsetzung schwierig ist deswegen
gehen wir auch ihren vorsichtigen weg
dies ist und bleibt kein normales
schuljahr es wurde war kein verlorenes
sein
unser ziel ist dass alle in der schule
im gesamten schuljahr natürlich wieder
kommen vor pfingsten die 50 prozent was
sind die maßgaben die wir haben hohe
qualität der abschlüsse der
kultusminister sagt wir können
garantieren dass wir in diesem jahr die
gleiche qualität beiden abschlüssen
haben oder weit gehen die gleiche wie
sonst keiner soll wegen corona nachteil
haben bei den abschlüssen
keiner muss aber auch wegen corona
sitzen bleiben also freiwilliges
versetzen auf probe ist jederzeit
möglich
seriosität geht vor schnelligkeit und
wir wollen erlerntes nicht mehr
verlangen das heißt die erfahrungen die
wir jetzt aus der digitalisierung
schöpfen soll auch zukünftig den
unterricht und die schule beleben
für den schutzraum schule gehört neben
hygiene konzepten abstand teilung von
klassen und eben auch dass infektionen
in der schule täglich
doch das thema maske dazu wir machen
keine maske im unterricht keine masken
pflicht im unterricht aber eine maske an
der schule dh pausenhof sanitäre
einrichtungen schul gänge bei job ist
einfach die möglichkeit ist abstand
zeiten sehr sehr schwierig der
unterricht rhythmus auch dame geredet
ist im wochenrhythmus im blockunterricht
der kultusminister wird es noch mal
sagen und was wir als ergänzung noch
machen für alle eltern die sehr besorgt
sind für alle eltern ist sehr besorgt
sind
wir haben bis vingst eine gelockerte
präsenzpflicht das heißt die eltern
können wenn sie sich selbst als
risikogruppe einschätzen können sie auch
weiter auf den digitalen schulweg setzen
und weniger auf die reine präsenz dort
ist man bis zu finster sehr flexibel
danke auch den schulämtern dann für die
bereitschaft diesen weg zu gehen
ferienzeiten bleiben die wird nicht
verkürzt aber es gibt notfallbetreuung
freiwillig es nach langen und wir werden
den noten schluss dieses jahr sehr spät
setzten ende juli so dass auch insgesamt
noch die möglichkeit besteht manches
nachzuholen wann welche klassen starten
wird der kurs müsste jetzt noch mal im
einzelnen darstellen also bei dem thema
familie erleichterung für senioren als
risikogruppe hilfe und unterstützung für
die eltern in dem schwierigen prozess
kinderbetreuung in der kita und in der
schule aber trotzdem vorsichtig und mit
bedacht und mit vielen flexiblen
möglichkeiten für die eltern zur
wirtschaft sehr sehr gut klappt seit
einer woche die öffnung des handels dort
wird die masken pflicht wie im öpnv sehr
gut umgesetzt
seit gestern sind auch die friseure
offen viele auch kabinettsmitglieder
beziehungsweise politiker kollegen haben
das schon genutzt ich selber habe ihm
bewusst noch keinen termin genau mit
last andere waren andere braucht auch
nicht aber das klappt sehr gut
das kann man sagen jetzt gehen wir die
nächsten schritte
ab nächster woche den 11 mai wird die
800 quadratmeter begrenzung aufgehoben
dh es bleiben die regeln wie jetzt 20
quadratmeter pro person maximale
personen einlass zahl masken pflicht
überall aber es wird die 800
quadratmeter begrenzung wird aufgehoben
behalten es für vertretbar
wichtig dies gilt auch für kaufhäuser
und auch für malls einziger unterschied
in malls muss generell in kauf weil
sowieso überall maske getragen werden
wir behalten uns eine ist aber vor
sollten sich regional zahlen irgendwo
verschlechtern oder nicht viel
verbessern nächsten tagen kann die 20
quadratmeter erhöht werden auf 30
quadratmetern um abstände an der stelle
zu erhöhen
und nächste woche öffnen dann auch
nagelstudios und kosmetik ähnlich wie
friseure unter den gleichen bedingungen
am schwersten war die debatte um
gastronomie wenn ich das so sagen darf
gastronomie deswegen war auf der einen
seite spüren wir ja die die
herausforderungen die unsere gastronomen
haben die auch keine ausweichmöglichkeit
haben wir wissen auch dass sehr viele
leute einfach sich freuen darauf mal wir
jetzt vielleicht zum essen gehen zu
können
an pfingsten steht vielleicht auch
urlaub an wie geht man damit um
aber andererseits ist es immer eine
besondere herausforderung warum bei
hygienemaßnahmen dort am schwierigsten
zu treffen so sind ansteckung ist durch
nähe leichter distanz zu halten
schwieriger insbesondere wenn man nicht
nur cola light bringt sondern was anders
und masken machen nur bedingt sinn in
einer gastronomischen einheit wenn uns
das sehr genau überlegt und habe in der
koalition dann glaube ich verantwortlich
entschieden
einige bundesländer gehen sehr schnell
voran die öffnen ab nächster woche
nahezu alles das tun wir nicht
ausdrücklich nicht ich gehe von hinten
her
wir werden zu pfingsten am 30 an dem
wochenende
werden wie hotel und tourismus zu lassen
allerdings ohne sauna ohne wellness ohne
schwimmbäder mit strengen hygienischen
konzepten
diese konzepte übrigens für alle
bereiche der gastronomie ermitteln die
gesundheitsministerin der
wirtschaftsminister und unser walter
nussel der für bürokratie fragen in den
fragen gut unterwegs ist also ab
pfingstsamstag den 30
medigene auflagen hotels im übrigen
dhabi nicht hundertprozentig wissen wie
die öffnung von grenzen möglicherweise
ist bis zu diesem zeitpunkt besteht
danach ein hervorragendes angebot in
bayern
es gibt also keinen anlass dann
möglicherweise in benachbarte länder
fahren zu müssen
parallel dazu ferienwohnungen und
natürlich campingplätze ausnahme dort
duschen ähnliches mehr
das wenn man nicht machen weil es eben
schwieriges zu der normalen gastronomie
können uns dann entschieden dass wir
alle sind stufen machen also der letzte
schritt in die hotels eine woche zuvor
am 25
wie ich ihn sagte ende mai halten wir
ein held ist auch unser landesamtes für
vertretbar speiselokale zu öffnen
mit sehr strengen aber sehr strengen
hygiene konzepten also gästezahl
begrenzt abstand halten zwar jeder
zweite tisch zonen für familien familien
tische sind wo einzelne sind ganz
besondere desinfektion für besteck
tische und gläser als auch temperatur
mit denen man die gläser dann drei nicht
zum spielen muss maske für küche und
keller und der vorschlag kam auch vom
wirtschaftsminister ich finde ihn sehr
gut
auch eine maske die man selber trägt
wenn man reinkommt zum platz und daneben
auch weil beispielsweise toiletten
ähnliches geht denn dort kann man nicht
ausreichend platz selber braucht man
natürlich keine maske tragen
speiselokale bis maximal 22 uhr und ein
dritter schritt den haben wir uns sehr
lange überlegt der war auch
die haben wir sehr genau abgewogen also
hotels als letztes daran die
speisegastronomie und als erstes weil
außen die ansteckung am geringsten ist
halten wir es am 18
für vertretbar und sehen es als
probebetrieb für außengastronomie die
allerdings nur bis 20 uhr mit ähnlichen
mit ähnlichen klaren vorgaben wie wir
sie jetzt gerade schon gesprochen haben
also es gibt eine entwicklung aber alles
zwei bis drei wochen später als andere
bundesländer zu kultur und freizeit nur
ganz wenig wir wären dann ab nächster
woche den bereich museen galerien
ausstellungen gedenkstätten und
bibliotheken mit hygiene konzepten ab
nächster woche eröffnen ebenso wie
tiergarten alles aber mit strengen
hygiene konzepten die kommunen zum
beispiel arbeiten auch sehr stark daran
dass vorzulegen also mit online-ticket
beispielsweise nur außen nicht innen und
ähnliches mehr zu dem thema freizeit
gehört auch der sport ab nächster woche
nicht wie manche bundesländer bereits
diese woche oder schon letzte woche ab
11 mai gibt es dann die möglichkeit für
kontaktlosen einzelsport im freien aber
kein mannschaftsfahren mannschaftssport
also spielt golf tennis segeln nahm
allein ist rudern motorboot
leichtathletik reitunterricht in der
halle ist das einzige wo es bislang sein
können in der halle weil die abstände
nahm groß sind überall mindestabstand
hygienemaßnahmen das sportministerium
hermann arbeitet gerade mit dem blsv für
andere sportarten mal konzepte durch die
machbar wären wie unterform anwendbar
zusammen mit melanie huml über theater
wird vorerst noch keine entscheidung
getroffen
da gibt es noch eine reihe von kultur
gesprächen die wir reden müssen
das muss erst in späteren zeitpunkten
ermittelt werden ich fasse jetzt
zusammen es gibt noch ein paar einzelne
punkte die man sagen kann ich fast noch
mal zusammen unser bayern plan bis
pfingsten
ist der von allen plänen die vorlegen
derzeit am spätesten entwickelte wir
haben früher begonnen gehören später auf
warum weil das infektionsgeschehen am
höchsten war bei der absolute zahl der
infektionen liegen wie auch nach wie vor
fahren
zum einen wird bayern bis zweitgrößte
bundesland ist zum teil weil wir halt
stärker betroffen waren
aber wir wählen den weg von maß und
mitte nicht stur abspann sondern ganz
langsam öffnet tat zeigen stufenweises
konzept kein stückwerk machen
das ist eine kombination aus vorsicht
und freiheit
wir halten es mit gutem gewissen für
vertretbar ich habe alle unsere experten
gefragt ist das vertretbar
sie sagen ja das kann man machen
ich möchte mich noch mal bedanken bei
allen die bislang so gut geduld bewahrt
ich bin übrigens auch weiter sich an
regeln zu halten verständnis zu zeigen
auch versammlungsfreiheit wahr zu nehmen
im interesse aller und nicht das
aussetzen zu wollen
wir müssen jetzt nicht lernen mit corona
umzugehen sondern wir müssen wieder mit
den neuen freiheiten
verantwortungsvoller leben der rest von
europa hat uns bislang bewundert manch
einer verwundert sich in europa das wir
jetzt und wie wir diskutieren
ich finde nur einfach dass wir den
vorsprung den deutschland und noch
bayern hatte in dieser krise nicht
leichtsinnig verspielen
corona bleibt also müssen wir wachsam
bleiben
aber was wir nicht wollen wir wollen
nicht dauerhaft die lebensfreude
verlieren
man kann auch lebensfreude haben wenn
man vernünftig und wachsam bleibt und
deswegen glaube ich ist der heutige tag
ein anlass zur ordentlichen
zwischenbilanz mit corona ein anlass zur
gebotenen vorsicht für die zukunft aber
schon ein stück auch anlass zu
optimismus
das ist wieder etwas aufwärts gehen kann
vielen dank
wirtschaftsminister hubert aiwanger
verehrten damen und herren mit dem
heutigen tag gehen wir einen ganz großen
schritt zur normalität in gesellschaft
und wirtschaft
mich freut es dass diese entscheidungen
heute so gefällt wurden dass wir jetzt
perspektive geben können diversen
branchen die in den letzten
tagen ja massiv schon an den türen
gerüttelt haben und haben gesagt wann
dürfen wir wieder öffnen
jetzt sind die zeitpläne da jetzt ist
die perspektive da wenn der handel hpf
dem mai wieder komplett öffnen darf dann
ist das ein großer schritt zur
normalität weil dann auch in diesen
branchen wieder geld verdient werden
kann weil dann diese branchen weniger
auf staatliche unterstützungsmaßnahmen
angewiesen sind weil dann irgendwann
wieder steuereinnahmen zurückfließen und
weil menschen aus der kurzarbeit in
beschäftigung kommen also diese öffnung
des handels ist für mich sehr wichtig
elfter mai richtiger zeitpunkt es geht
weiter mit dem bereich der gastronomie
wo ja in den letzten wochen die größten
debatten gewesen sind weil sie mit
sicherheit nicht nur ein
wirtschaftlicher aspekt sind unsere
werte unsere hotels unsere restaurants
sondern auch ein gesellschaftlich sehr
wichtiger faktor sind ich gehe sogar so
weit zu sagen dass unsere gastronomie
systemrelevant für die gesellschaft ist
für das soziale zusammenleben ist es
geht ja nicht nur um die mahlzeit um und
um das getränk dass man dort zu sich
nehmen kann sondern eben um den
geselligen austausch dort geht es auch
um die seele bayerns und deshalb ist
auch die öffnung der biergärten jetzt
zum 18 mal in meinen augen der richtige
schritt wir werden das ordentlich
vorbereitet und ich glaube dass sich
hier sehr schnell eine außengastronomie
und der biergarten kultur entwickeln
wird wo wir dann am besten und am
deutlichsten sehen dass die menschen
wieder zusammenkommen können wieder
miteinander reden können
ich appelliere hier auch an die kommunen
im bereich der außenbereiche großzügig
zu sein mit stellplatzverordnung in und
dergleichen mehr
das eben die gastronomen die noch bis 25
mai den innenraum geschlossen haben
müssen dann wenigstens draußen tische
aufstellen dürfen das gilt in der stadt
münchen genauso wie am land draußen das
hier maßvolle gebühren erhoben werden
dass man hier ja etwas mehr stellfläche
zu billig dass man in der vergangenheit
vielleicht zugebilligt hat damit man
eben dieses
die innenräume im außenbereich noch
kompensiert und ich bitte den lieben
gott oder bisschen schönes wetter
wollten zulassen dass wir auch draußen
sitzen können nicht dass die freifläche
geöffnet ist und es schüttet aus kübeln
selbst wenn es die landwirte wieder
freude aber das wird sich schon richten
ich hoffe dass wir dann dieses
biergarten wetter genießen können
es geht dann weiter eben mit dem thema
am 25 mai die innen gastronomie wo wir
sehr gute konzepte vor stellen müssen
und werden gemeinsam mit den
gaststättenbetreibern das einfach hier
das infektionsrisiko massivst reduziert
es dass wir hier die speisen auch
drinnen wieder anbieten können und ob 30
mai dann auch der durchbruch im
tourismus in dem wir dann für
touristische zwecke die hotels die
campingplätze die ferienwohnungen wieder
öffnen können also auch hier haben ja
viele viele leute schon lange darauf
gewartet ersten mal als kunden wann kann
ich wieder urlaub machen wann kann ich
raus aus meinen vier wänden wo mir die
decke vielleicht schon auf den kopf
fällt heraus in die freie natur und darf
auch dort übernachten muss nicht abends
wieder heim fahren also hiermit glaube
ich ist ein deutliches zeichen gesetzt
wo wir hin wollen wo wir hin müssen
ich bitte die gastronomen diese paar
wochen noch durchzuhalten ist sie so in
den letzten wochen als ihr lauter ruf
geworden also wenn ihr nicht
schnellstens öffnet dann hört ein
drittel auf es sind hier wirklich
dramatische zahlen genannt wurden von
betrieben die das handtuch werfen
wollten
ich hoffe wir können das abmildern wir
können die im spiel halten
aktuell wird auch diskutiert über das
thema der autoindustrie hier sie auf
bundesebene ja auch eine entscheidung in
aussicht als bayerischer
wirtschaftsminister unterstütze ich auf
alle fälle die pläne für kaufprämien von
autos da können wir jetzt 1000 da hin
oder her diskutieren aber auf alle fälle
soll es technologieoffen sein dass es
also nicht nur elektroautos betrifft die
gefördert werden die in vielen fällen
gar nicht in deutschland und bayern
produziert werden sondern damit würden
wir importfahrzeuge finanzieren mit
unserem steuergeld also ich bin durchaus
ein anhänger darf ja auch die
verbrennung
motoren in höchster qualität zu
unterstützen und auch die debatte müsse
man den die autoindustrie unterstützen
nein meine damen und herren es geht hier
nicht um einen bösen industriellen die
sind nicht böse die schaffen
arbeitsplätze sondern es geht um die
vielen hunderttausend arbeitern
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer in
der zulieferbranche in der autoindustrie
die in der kurzarbeit sitzen derzeit die
sich nur beschränkt ja im konsum bewegen
können weil die gelder sind die froh
sind wenn sie ihre miete bezahlen können
je mehr von diesen menschen auch durch
anreiz prämien beim verkauf von autos
wieder in die vollbeschäftigung kommen
umso besser ist das bayern ist auto land
und ich lasse auch keine ideologischen
debatten zu und wenn einige sagen ja wir
sollen fahrräder fördern
über solche dinge kann man nachdenken
aber das löst die großen probleme dieses
wirtschaftszweiges industrie
autoindustrie nicht also klares
bekenntnis zur bayerischen zur deutschen
autoindustrie technologieoffen fördern
auch dem verbrenner eine chance geben
wenn er moderne technik hat damit haben
wir dann auch an dieser front glaube ich
sehr wichtige signale gesetzt und wieder
zur normalität zurückzukehren wir haben
derzeit in deutschland über 10 millionen
kurzarbeiter in bayern an die zwei
millionen menschen in kurzarbeit bei 13
millionen einwohnern über 120000
betriebe haben jetzt schon kurzarbeit
angemeldet weitere werden hinzukommen
diese zahl werden noch weiter steigen
also es ist höchste zeit dass wir auch
hier den patienten wirtschaft wieder die
infusion geben die ihr und der stelle
braucht und diese infusion ist ein
zirkulieren der geschäftsbetrieb ist das
einkaufsverhalten der bevölkerung ist
die erkenntnis es geht schon weiter und
wir müssen nicht noch lang in quarantäne
bleiben denn wer zu hause in der wohnung
sitzt und nicht raus darf der kauft auch
kein neues auto aber wenn man wieder
raus darauf immer wieder im biergarten
darf wenn man wieder seine freunde
treffen darf wenn man wieder zur oma
fahren darf dann kauft man auch wieder
ein neues auto und ich sage ganz klar
dass damit diese sache für mich
grund ist handel geöffnet gastronomie
mit perspektive autoindustrie wieder
angeworfen und jetzt müssen wir die
dinge alle zu ende führen wir sind auch
hier freut dass die branchen die derzeit
ein bissel im windschatten worden von
den kosmetikern bis zu anderen
berufszweigen die domain friesinger
wieder vergleichbar sind das die auch
wieder ihr eigenes geld endlich wieder
verdienen dürfen auch die haben lange
darauf gewartet das kommt jetzt alles
und wenn wir am ende dann noch die zoos
und tiergärten öffnen dann kann man
wieder einen kleinen familienausflug
machen damit der weg zurück zur realität
eingeleitet und europa zahlen zum
finanziellen sie wissen ja dass zum
wirtschaftsministerium auch die edv
förderbank gehört wo wir eine reihe von
kredit werkzeugen in den letzten wochen
ihr sonnen haben die passgenau helfen
damit betriebe über die krise hinweg
überbrückungs gegner bekommen da ist ab
heute eine neuerung dass es einen
kolonie schnell kredit gibt bis zu fünf
mitarbeitern 50.000 abzüglich
soforthilfe also maximal 9000 weniger
bis zu zehn mitarbeiter 100.000
abzüglich maximal 15.000 soforthilfe
sofian beantragt und damit können die ja
jetzt für viele jahre einen kredit
bekommen auf sechs jahre zunächst neu
oder fünf jahre und zehn jahre sechs
jahren ist in andere kreditmodelle mit
3% zinssorgen zwar viele ist er relativ
hoher zins aber sie brauchen keine
sicherheit dafür hinterlegen und sie
bekommen diesen kredit sehr schnell
hinzu kommt noch die soforthilfe die
ausbezahlt wird wo wir derzeit rund 1,5
milliarden euro schon ausbezahlt haben
und über 250.000 antragsteller eine
riesen antragsflut die es hier zu
bewältigen gilt es muss genau
hingeschaut werden es wird genau
hingeschaut geld fließt trotzdem also
hier sind wir gut unterwegs um auch die
firmen um die unternehmer flüssig zu
halten und jetzt geht es einfach darum
immer mehr wegzukommen von staatlichen
finanziellen förderprogrammen hin dazu
dass die wirtschaft wieder sein eigenes
geld verdienen kann ich hoffe das läuft
auch international jetzt hoch dann ist
mir um den patient wirtschaft zwar
momentan noch sorge aber ich gehe davon
aus dass er gelesen wird das für die
starke bayerische wirtschaft stück für
stück auch wieder zu alter stärke
zurückführen können
sozialministerin carolina trautner
wir haben eine sehr geehrten damen und
herren auch im bereich der
kinderbetreuung sind wir natürlich vor
großen herausforderungen gestanden und
stehen sie noch heute für die familien
ist es nicht einfach und auch für die
kinder die vermissen inzwischen ihre
freundinnen und freunde aber auch in
diesem bereich hatte gesundheitsschutz
oberste priorität das wissen wir alle
wir müssen achten auf die kinder die
eltern und natürlich auch vor allem auf
die beschäftigten und deren familien
deshalb wir wissen alle dass kinder die
noch sehr klein sind sich schwer tun mit
den abstandsregeln mit den
hygienemaßnahmen die man einhalten muss
und deshalb wollen wir da auch sehr
umsichtig vorgehen
wir wissen dass die erzieherinnen und
erzieher vor ort sehr praktische und
gute lösungen schon gefunden haben in
den wochen der notbetreuung und ich
möchte an dieser stelle ein ganz
herzliches dankeschön sagen an die
erzieherinnen und erzieher die unsere
allergrößte wertschätzung verdienen für
das was sie tagtäglich hier leisten
sie sind nicht nur in der not betreuung
tätig sondern sie kümmern sich auch um
die kinder die zu hause sind sehr viele
innovative konzepte sind hier entstanden
ich habe ein expertengremium einberufen
pädagogen mediziner psychologen und
praktika und die begleiten uns bei
unseren entscheidungen und geben uns
wertvolle hilfen wie wir auch das gut
umsetzen können
es ist wichtig dass es kleine möglichst
kleine feste gruppen sind die hier von
den festen bezugspersonen betreut werden
wir wollen auch keine offenen gruppen
also kein gruppenübergreifende austausch
soll im moment nicht stattfinden
wir legen allergrößten wert darauf dass
kranke kinder nicht gebracht werden
dürfen kranke kinder müssen zu hause
bleiben
das ist mir ganz ganz wichtig dass hier
an dieser stelle nochmal zu betonen
die bringen und abholzeiten sollten
möglichst gestaffelt werden damit wir
hier auch nicht große mengen an eltern
haben und geschwisterkindern am schluss
noch die sich da noch begegnen also da
muss man aufpassen
zum thema masken kinder können natürlich
keine masken tragen und auch die
erzieherinnen und erzieher tun sich
schwer kleine kinder brauchen die mimik
des erwachsenen um kontakt aufnehmen zu
können
wir haben empfohlen dass es in gewissen
planbaren situationen wenn enger kontakt
mit dem kind besteht zum beispiel beim
wickeln oder beim füttern dass die
erzieherinnen einen mund nasen schutz
verwendet der hygieneplan ist natürlich
ein zu halten es ist auch ganz klar und
die erzieher sollten sich im kontakt
untereinander also mit erwachsenen
personen erzählt zu erzieher oder bei
elterngesprächen auch entsprechend
schützen wenn der abstand nicht
eingehalten werden kann
denken wir auch an plexiglasscheiben
oder telefonische elterngespräche ja der
herr ministerpräsident hat schon gesagt
kinder brauchen auch andere kinder und
jetzt wird ein bisschen druck aus der
sache genommen indem wir private
spielgruppen zulassen dass sich die
nachbarschaft gegenseitig unterstützt
und hilft mit bis maximal drei familien
wir legen auch hier größten wert auf die
eigenverantwortung der eltern die auch
feste gruppen hier bilden das immer
nachvollziehbar sein sollte wenn hier
einen erkrankungsfall auftreten soll
dass ihr wissen wie die infektionskette
nachzuverfolgen ist das soll
wechselseitig geschehen die kinder haben
wieder andere kinder zum spielen und die
eltern werden entlastet wenn sie eine
berufstätigkeit nachgehen müssen
wir wollen ab dem 11
auch anderen gruppen noch zugang zur not
betreuung geben
herr ministerpräsident hat angedeutet
erstens kinder mit behinderung oder mit
drohender behinderung die einen bescheid
auf eingliederungshilfe haben das ist
eine klar definierte gruppe die auch
einen besonderen unterstützungsbedarf
hat zum zweiten kinder mit
erzieherischen bedarf also eltern die
einen anspruch auf hilfen zur erziehung
haben auch hier besteht großer
unterstützungsbedarf und da wollen wir
auch
erleichterungen schaffen wir haben
bereits die berufstätigen
alleinerziehenden und wollen das noch
ausweiten auf studierende
alleinerziehende die auch einen anspruch
haben sollen
im gleichklang zu den privaten
elterngruppen die ich schon erwähnt habe
möchten wir auch die normale tagespflege
öffnen mit maximal fünf kindern die hier
betreut werden
ich glaube das ist auch eine familie
neue betreuungsformen und westen bezugs
partner und das ist eine kleine feste
gruppe dass es sehr vertretbar und
natürlich in abhängigkeit dann von der
schule der kollege piazolo wird ja auch
noch dazu sprechen dann entsprechend die
hortkinder der klassen die in der
grundschule beschult werden ab dem 25
mai wollen wir weiter dann zu lassen die
vorschulkinder die natürlich ein stück
weit älter sind und die hygienemaßnahmen
besser verstehen können als ganz ganz
kleine kinder und wir haben auch gesagt
der kindergarten hat auch einen
bestimmten bildungsauftrag insofern
wollten wir die vorschulkinder unbedingt
als erste gruppe mit hinein nimmt auch
um ihnen gelegenheit zu geben sich von
ihrem kindergarten leben ein stück weit
zu verabschieden denn sie treten dann im
herbst in einen neuen lebensabschnitt
als schulkind ein und auch das halten
wir für sehr sinnvoll
im gleichen schritt wollen wir auch dann
die großtagespflege öffnen
auch hier ist eine überschaubare gruppe
da werden maximal zehn kinder betreut
und auch das wurde schon gesagt wir
denken auch dann an die öffnung von
waldkindergärten die kindergärten
bewegen sich sehr viel an der frischen
luft in enger begleitung mit
gesundheitsamt und jugendamt es muss
lösungen geben für ein ersatz eines ganz
engen bauwagens wenn es wirklich
ausströmen schützen sollte also hier
wollen wir aber auch diese kindergarten
art unterstützen wir denken weiter an
geschwisterkinder die in schritten auch
mit betreut werden müssen
es muss immer ausreichend pädagogisches
personal vorhanden sein das ist ganz
klar die herausforderungen waren in den
letzten wochen sehr sehr groß und ich
danke wirklich allen die sich hier
sehr verantwortungsbewusst verhalten
haben und ja dazu beigetragen haben dass
wir das sehr gut meistern konnten
ich bin nicht nur beeindruckt von der
solidarität sondern auch von der
kreativität aller die hier in diesem
bereich gearbeitet haben und auch zu
hause unterstützt haben
es geht um das wertvollste was wir haben
uns das kostbarste es geht um unsere
kinder die eine gute zukunft haben
sollen
und bei allem was wir gerade tun es ist
vielleicht wichtig dass wir sagen es
geht immer um jeden einzelnen und
gleichzeitig um das große ganze hat
vielen dank kultusminister professor
michael piazolo
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ich glaube dieser bayern plan den wir
jetzt aufgesetzt haben es wohl
ausgewogen auch in den einzelnen
bereichen auch im schulbereich ich freue
mich gerade auch als zuständiger
minister dass jetzt mit unserem fahrplan
schaffen wieder mehr und mehr
schülerinnen und schüler an die schulen
zu bekommen
es wird wieder mehr unterricht live vor
ort geben das ist mir ein großes
anliegen und deshalb habe ich auch gerne
das mit auf den weg gebracht die
grundsätze die uns geleitet haben sei
noch mal in der kürze erwähnt zum einen
die orientierung am infektionsgeschehen
deshalb haben wir damals für mitte märz
als erste in bayern die
schulschließungen beschlossen die
anderen länder sind danach gezogen und
wir sind jetzt auch diejenigen die am
deutlichsten auch einen fahrplan
aufzeigen wie es dann mit den öffnungen
weitergeht wir tun das deshalb und dass
ich die quintessenz diese öffnungen
immer in enger absprache mit dem
staatsministerium für gesundheit und
pflege
das ist mir ganz wichtig das zweite ist
schon kurz erwähnt worden
schule ist natürlich ein besonderes
schutzraum die im eltern
geben uns ihre kinder in die schule und
erwarten dort auch möglichst hohen
schutz immer zu allen zeiten aber
natürlich auch besonders in zeiten
dieser pandemie
das werden wir auch sicherstellen schule
wird sicher sein möglichst sicher
deshalb werden wir auch schrittweise
wieder die schulen öffnen das haben wir
schon getan die ersten schritte den
ersten schritt weitere werden folgen
also seriosität solidität vor
schnelligkeit
es ist sicherlich keine rückkehr in die
normalität
sondern es ist wird kein normales
schuljahr seien aber es ist auch eines
wo man vieles lernen für die schule aber
auch fürs leben insofern natürlich kein
verlorenes schuljahr wir werden allen
die chance zu geben auf den erwerb der
abschlüsse und auch das ist erwähnt
worden ich kann das nur noch mal
unterstützen
wir wollen auch den hohen
qualitätsanspruch für den nun bayerns
abschlüsse stehen bundes- europa- er
sogar weltweit den wollen wir erhalten
und werden deshalb auch für faire examen
habe sorgen für faire prüfungen aber
auch prüfungen mit denen man sich sehen
lassen kann
es gibt kein corona bedingtes
durchfallen vorrücken auf probe wird es
geben das heißt der inhaltliche anspruch
den wir an die schulen an unsere schüler
berichteten der bleibt bestehen wird
aber natürlich entsprechend auch dem der
korona ab krise entsprechend natürlich
abgewandelt wir werden das ganze
behutsam und auch achtsam weiter
fortführen
wichtig ist schule ist nicht nur ein
reinraum ein schutzraum sondern
natürlich auch ein raum in dem soziale
interaktionen stattfinden und deshalb
das ist ganz wichtig dass diejenigen die
diesen dieser schule verantwortlich sind
aber die auch anja teilnehmen
aufeinander aufpassen
das heißt gegenseitige rücksichtnahme
intensive begegnung werden stattfinden
und der sagt geht alles immer nur
gemeinsam
in der schulfamilie das hat in den
letzten wochen gut funktioniert
schüler eltern lehrkräfte schulleitungen
die verbände und viele mehr
auch das ministerium haben gut
zusammengearbeitet
unser fahrplan sind vier stufen die wir
beschreiten wollen die eine ist schon
eingeleitet haben 27 viertel haben wir
die schulen geöffnet mit den
abschlussklassen alle weiterführenden
schulen und beruflichen es ist gut
angelaufen wir haben positive
rückmeldungen
das ziel war insbesondere diejenigen
möglichst früh an die schulen wieder
zurückzubringen die zum einen dazu in
der lage sind weil sie keine
vorschriften möglichst gut auch
einhalten können zum anderen aber auch
für die prüfungsvorbereitung notwendig
die prüfungsvorbereitung findet statt in
den kernfächern ja weitgehend klausuren
erlassen
zweiter schritt jetzt am elften fünften
nächste woche wollen wir wie schon
angedeutet wenn nun beschlossen die vor
abschlussklassen in die schulen mit
hineinnehmen plus die vierte klasse
grundschule
das bedeutet am gymnasium aber auch den
anderen weiterführenden schulen die
klassen die im nächsten jahr ihre
prüfungen schreiben im gymnasium die
elfte in den real stunden die neunte
klasse in der mittelschule die achte und
auch in den berufsschulen dann die
sogenannten vor abschluss klassen in der
grundschule die wirte aber auch in der
förderschule entsprechend
beziehungsweise auch wenn die
förderschule daten zum
mittelschulabschluss so das führt auch
die vor abschlussklasse und auch die
schule für kranke
da ist es ähnlich die vierte
grundschulklasse warum sie besonders
jetzt im zweiten schritt da geht es um
zwei dinge sind diejenigen die jetzt vor
dem übertritt stehen und auf die
weiterführenden schulen vorbereitet
werden und zum zweiten steht für den ein
oder anderen auch der probeunterricht
aus wenn man vielleicht den
entsprechenden schnitt noch nicht in der
tasche hat aber dann doch an die
realschule oder das gymnasium will
werden wir
zielt darauf vorbereiten in
entsprechenden kleingruppen der dritte
schritt weiter folgen haben 18 5 und am
25.05
wir haben uns lange gedanken gemacht und
miteinander ausgetauscht mit den
lehrerverbänden aber auch innerhalb des
kabinetts zu welcher gruppe wir
zusätzlich mit aufnehmen wollen und
haben uns jetzt entschieden
insbesondere auch die jüngeren schüler
in der jeweiligen schulart mit
aufzunehmen das sind insbesondere
diejenigen die auch zum großen teil bis
jetzt zu hause betreut sind und wo viele
eltern auch langsam unruhiger werden
obwohl sie ihre kinder natürlich lieben
und gerne um sich sehen ist es ihnen
vielleicht ganz lieb wenn sie zumindest
teilweise auch in die obhut der schulen
gelassen werden
das bedeutet dass wir bei den
weiterführenden schulen im gymnasium die
fünfte und sechste klasse dann in
jeweils zwei geteilten gruppen
wochenweise am 18 05
beginnend mit der gruppe a am 25.5 dann
beginnt mit der gruppe b im jeweiligen
wechsel alternierend aufnehmen werden
auch in der realschule fünfter und
sechster in der mittelschule die fünfte
auch teilweise in der förderschule haben
die fünfte auch in der wirtschaftsschule
die jeweils niedrigste dann
eingangsklasse und wir haben uns in der
grundschule auch nach intensiven
gesprächen und diskussionen daraufhin
ständig das liegt gleichermaßen auch für
die förderschule die erste klasse mit
aufzunehmen das sind diese die
schülerinnen und schüler die noch nicht
soviel schule hatten und für die
natürlich jetzt die für sechs wochen
besonders ein langer zeitraum war
verglichen mit ihrer lebenszeit und mit
der zeit die sie in der schule waren
das ist uns besonders wichtig wir werden
in der grundschule aber auch
das sage ich ja auch für die zweite und
dritte klasse die wir jetzt noch nicht
hinein nehmen ein schmales angebot vor
ort machen da sage ich aber auch ganz
deutlich das geht zurück auf die atmende
strategie die angesprochen worden ist
wir müssen da zweierlei sehen wir müssen
sehen wie das infektionsgeschehen sich
entwickelt wir müssen aber auch schauen
aber noch keine erfahrungswerte an der
grundschule wie auch die risikogruppen
sind insbesondere auch bei den
lehrkräften ja und deshalb ist in diesem
bereich viele eigenverantwortlichkeit
von den schulen erwartet das werden wir
entsprechend noch ausgestalten und dann
weil wir ja auch immer um pfingsten
herum in den blick genommen haben am
15.06 wollen wir den vierten schritt
gehen mit als ziel mit den restlichen
jahrgangsstufen wenn sage ich
ausdrücklich das infektionsgeschehen es
zulässt auch ein paar stichworte zum
ablauf geteilte klassen kleine gruppen
keine klassen nach möglichkeit über 15
es sei denn die räumlichkeiten gebe es
mit dem entsprechenden abstand her
ein wechsel zwischen den präsenzphasen
und dem lernen zu hause bei das prinzip
dann schon gilt soviel schule live wie
auch möglich aber das eben im
wochenwechsel strenge
hygienevorschriften das heißt abstand
von 1,5 meter beziehungsweise vier
quadratmeter in den schulen
ich will noch ein wort sagen nochmal
ergänzend zum thema was ausgeführt
worden ist zu den masken
wir hatten jetzt bisher bei der gruppe
von fair 14 prozent der schüler im
unterricht keine masken pflicht
außerhalb des unterrichts ein
ich habe gesagt ich halte es für sehr
angemessen das zu tun ein gewisses gebot
ich glaube wenn wir jetzt mehr schüler
mit hineinnehmen im nächsten schritt
sind dann über 30 prozent die in der
schule sein werden
im übernächsten schritt die 50 prozent
dann halte ich es nicht nur für geboten
sondern für eine pflicht dass wir bei
bestimmten begegnungsverkehr das heißt
außerhalb des unterrichts aber in
der schule oder im pausenhof die maske
zur pflicht machen
das bringt auch höhere sicherheit wir
wollen den unterricht bis zum
schuljahresende machen es wird ja keine
projekte keine schulfahrten geben
deshalb ist das auch möglich dann auch
nach pfingsten im wochenwechsel in den
sechs wochen dann jeweils unterricht
auch bis zum jahresende schuljahresende
zu machen die ferien bleiben wir werden
aber auch die notfallbetreuung in den
ferien sicherstellen wir werden das
liegt aber auch daran dass nicht alle
lehrerinnen und lehrer zur verfügung
stehen und wir auch weniger räume haben
den stoff anpassen an die jeweilige
situation das heißt differenziert nach
alter und schulart und mit großer auch
eigenverantwortlichkeit der schulen vor
ort ist ist aber reduziert im umfang was
mir ganz wichtig ist ist der schutz der
risikogruppen sowohl bei den lehrerinnen
und lehrern als auch bei den
schülerinnen und schülern
wir werden auch bei den lehrerinnen und
lehrer weiter darauf achten dass die die
in den risikogruppen sind dann im beim
lernen zu hause eingesetzt werden nicht
im präsenzunterricht ehrlich ob es
pfingsten bei den über 60-jährigen und
wir werden und das ist neu halte ich
aber auch für sehr wichtig auch bei den
schülerinnen und schülern bis pfingsten
ist so handhaben dass wenn eine
besondere situation nicht beim schüler
selber wenn der schüler selber gar nicht
risikogruppe ist aber in seinem
familiären umfeld das ja dann oder sie
entscheiden kann natürlich die eltern
dass das kind nicht an präsenzunterricht
teilnimmt ich habe viele zuschriften
erreicht ganz unterschiedlich von eltern
die sagen sofort alles öffnen und viele
aber auch die gesagt haben das schuljahr
überhaupt nicht mehr für geöffnet und
gerade gibt es viele die sorgen haben
und den wollen wir diese sorgen nehmen
auch für ihre verwandten dass die kinder
die vielleicht selber geringere symptome
haben aber nicht ihre eltern oder
großeltern die zu den risikogruppen
gehören anstecken
das heißt insgesamt das will ich auch
noch mal deutlich machen werden wir als
ministerium natürlich einen
entsprechenden rahmen vorgeben und auch
vorgaben machen das heißt zu den bisher
knapp über 100 km es werden weitere
kultusministerien schreiben in
mindestens zweistelliger zahl dazu
kommen da wird schon seit dieser woche
intensiv gearbeitet und auch damit man
nicht das große mysterium des falschen
zeit auch in dieser nacht wurde
ich habe die letzte sms um 1 uhr 34
bekommen heute früh
und dann da wird also daran gearbeitet
und man wartet auch die beschlüsse die
wir fällen
wir werden aber auch
gestaltungsspielraum den profis vor ort
lassen unseren lehrkräften unseren
schulleiterinnen und schulleitern die
eine sehr sehr gute arbeit gemacht haben
und es gibt natürlich in bayern als
flächenstaat kleinere schulen im
ländlichen raum mit viel platz wo man
mehr machen kann aber auch dann
städtische schulen muss ein bisschen
enger ist wir werden auch rücksicht
nehmen auf die risikogruppen und werden
deshalb auch diese atmende strategie
weiter fortfahren
ein kurzes fazit ich bin der festen
überzeugung dass ist ein ausgewogenes
konzept ich weiß aber auch dass manchmal
auch deutlich sagen wir können es das
gilt auch die anderen bereiche natürlich
nicht allen recht machen
wir hatten in den vergangenen tagen
bundesweit eine sehr intensive und
kontroverse diskussion
er hat mich natürlich als
verfassungsrechtler auch habe ich
spannend verfolgt über priorisierung von
grundwerten wie leben freiheit und würde
des menschen ja was ist das wichtigste
ganz schwierig kann man sehr schön
diskutieren hat ein hohes abstraktion
niveau aber in einer pluralistischen
gesellschaft findet jeder für sich seine
werte ja der eine sagt die freiheit ist
mir besonders wichtig bei andere sagt
die sicherheit ist mir besonders wichtig
und deshalb werden wir als staat nie
jedem seine werte in gänze erfüllen
können
unsere vorschriften sind immer
ausgerichtet dass vieles auch generell
und ab
trakt geregelt wird das müssen wir
gerade auch in einer allgemeinverfügung
der einzelne aber möchte die dinge
individuellen konkret so geregelt wissen
wie er es haben möchte und das geht
nicht immer eins zu eins auf unser
ansatz und ich glaube der ist uns auch
gelungen ist dass wir mit diesen
generellen und abstrakten lösungen die
wir anbieten doch sehr sehr vielen
entgegenkommen und das in alle
abstraktheit und generalität doch vieles
individuelle auch sich dann
verwirklichen kann
zum abschluss letzte bemerkung mein dank
an diejenigen die in den letzten wochen
mitgeholfen haben in dieser corona krise
und corona zeit doch für die
schülerinnen und schüler das beste
rauszuholen das war für die lehrerinnen
und lehrer eine große umstellung auch in
richtung lernen zu hause aber es auch
natürlich für die eltern die hier in
zusammenarbeit mit den lehrerinnen und
lehrer auch großartiges geleistet haben
vielen dank und ich bitte um verständnis
dass wir nicht ab sofort wieder alles
hoch fahren könnten dass wir auch nicht
angemessen auch dem infektionsgeschehen
nicht angemessen sondern dass wir
schrittweise machen aber mit einem
konkreten fahrplan auf denen sie sich
auch einstellen können und mit konkreten
vorgaben sowohl für den unterricht in
der schule als auch für das lernen zu
hause
dankeschön diese ministerin melanie huml
ja meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
liebe ministerpräsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen auch ich darf
sagen erst einmal dankeschön an alle die
mitgemacht haben bisher und sich so gut
an die bisher beschlossenen maßnahmen
gehalten haben weil das hat dazu geführt
dass wir unser gesundheitssystem nicht
überlastet haben das hat dazu geführt
dass wir heute über leichteren
entsprechen können
aber es ist auch notwendig diese
erleichterungen jetzt voran zu bringen
wir haben den heute von gestern auf
heute eine steigerungsrate von 0 4
prozent gehabt also man merkt und die
letzten tage war das immer sehr stabil
gewesen der ministerpräsiden du dich
schon früh morgens immer als erstes auf
die zahlen
und überlegen dann was wie kann man
weiter voran gehen und für bayern ist es
eben wichtig dass wir unserem in unserem
tempo die dinge auch angehen und
deswegen mag sein dass manches
vielleicht ein paar tage später ist als
in einem anderen bundesland
aber wir wollen auch diesen
verantwortlichen umgang mit dieser
corona erkrankung und deswegen ist es
eben auch hier wichtig aber wir brauchen
auch die perspektiven wir brauchen die
perspektiven eben für die verschiedenen
branchen und wir sind ja da in vielen
gesprächen und auch in der ausarbeitung
immer wieder mit schutzkonzepte hygiene
konzepten egal ob es jetzt im
kindergartenbereich es im schulbereich
ist oder auch im bereich der gastronomie
dann sind wir da auch fachlich bereits
im gespräch wie können maßnahmen
aussehen um eben dann jetzt auch
vorbereitet zu sein
welche überlegungen gibt es da wie
können wir schutz einerseits weiter
gewährleisten und gleichzeitig aber auch
wieder mehr erleichterungen hier
ermöglichen
und wenn es jetzt den bereich auch
betrifft wo menschen gerade in
situationen sind wo sie pflegebedürftig
sind wo sie krank im krankenhaus liegen
wo sie eben besonders eigentlich in ganz
normalen zeiten sozusagen ihre familie
um sich haben wollen dass wir hier die
letzten wochen ein besuchsverbot
auferlegen mussten ist uns allen nicht
leicht gefallen und ich habe viele
zuschriften bekommen auch von
familienangehörigen die mir berichtet
haben wie schwer es ihnen fällt nach
normalerweise täglichen besuchen bei der
frau bei der schwiegermutter jetzt nicht
mehr ins pflege und seniorenheim zu
können und wie das sowohl für die
betroffene im pflegeheim aber auch für
die angehörigen ist und dass es eben ich
hier auch notwendig ist wieder einiges
an möglichkeiten zu schaffen
obwohl das gerade hier ein bereich ist
wo wir sehr genau auch darauf schauen
wie sie sich entwickelt weil wenn gerade
eine corona erkrankungen
einem seniorenheim auftritt haben wir
eben in den letzten wochen sehr häufig
schwer erkrankte oder auch todesfälle
gehabt deswegen ist es ein sehr
sensibler bereich und deswegen wollen
wir hier auch ganz speziell noch drauf
schauen das heißt aber auch wir wollen
ab 19 uhr öffnungen zu lassen
das eben hier wieder besuch ermöglicht
wird warum neunter mai weil eben auch
die pflegeheime die träger vor ort
entsprechende konzeptionen auch noch
erarbeiten müssen
wir sind auch mit den
wohlfahrtsverbänden im austausch schon
dass hier eben auch überlegungen bereits
von den verschiedenen trägern auch da
sind und die das dann auch umgesetzt
werden kann dabei ist es notwendig und
wichtig dass wir auch testungen
vornehmen dass wir auch gucken wie
schaut es mit der ausrüstung an
materialien aus und wir werden was den
bereich der testungen betrifft vor allem
auch hier testungen vornehmen wo eben
infektionsgeschehen da ist bzw da wo
eben in den landkreisen sogenannte
hotspots regionen also das heißt da wo
eben die inzidenz raten also sprich pro
100000 einwohner wie viele fälle sind in
der woche da und dann schauen wir uns an
welche regionen lokal sind besonders
betroffen
und in diesen regionen werden wir dann
speziell auch in senioren- und
altenheimen und krankenhäusern
eben hier testungen vornehmen weil wir
wollen hier immer auch lokal abgestimmt
dann schauen welche konzepte notwendig
sind was sind auch für nächste maßnahmen
eben nicht hier dann auch wichtig das
heißt wir werden weiter die test
kapazitäten das haben wir schon mehrfach
erwähnt dass die nach oben gefahren
werden dass es uns auch bisher gut
gelungen wir haben eben mich hier test
kapazitäten inzwischen am 21 april 118
1590 gewesen knapp 50 labore in bayern
die uns auch sagen das dies noch weiter
ausweiten können bis zu diesen 25 26 gab
es 30.000 und wir wollen eben auch diese
möglichkeiten nutzt
aber vor allem speziell auch da gezielt
testen wo entweder infektionsketten oder
herde da sind oder wo eben bestimmte
regionen da sind wo wir merken wie es in
fact geschehen und dann noch mal
speziell in die senioren und altenheime
mit reingehen um hier frühzeitig dann
auch mögliche infekt ketten mit
austreten zu können das heißt aber auch
dass wir eben die gesundheitsämter
weiter gut vorbereiten
wir haben ja die das personal hier auch
aufstocken können
wir haben im moment ca 2000
unterstützungskräfte im kontakt tracing
in den teams das sind knapp 400 teams
die hier auch schon an den
gesundheitsämtern vor ort tätig sind die
eben da wo infektionen sind die infect
ketten genau eingrenzen
weil wenn wir erleichterungen auf der
einen seite haben ist es umso wichtiger
da wo infekt ketten infektionsgeschehen
sind die frühzeitig zu erkennen und dann
eingrenzen zu können
um eben sie nicht in weitere
bevölkerungsgruppen mit ausbreiten zu
lassen und das dass der an der stelle
hiermit das wichtigste wir haben diese
software dich mit der kollegin judith
gernach vorgestellt habe die wird
inzwischen seit 27
april an den ersten gesundheitsämtern
getestet auch hier geht es darum diese
infekt ketten lückenlos möglichst nach
zu vollziehen zu können und das wird
auch noch weiter ausgeweitet werden
weiter sind wir in der
materialbeschaffung dabei testung
ausweiten
gesundheitsämter unterstützen und die
kolleginnen und kollegen in den
verschiedenen hygiene konzepten die
notwendig sind auch immer wieder mit ich
hier uns einzubringen zu beraten
und auch die entsprechenden konzeptionen
mit vorzubereiten weil es eben auch
immer wichtig ist dass der schutz
weiterhin in unseren köpfen dabei
bleiben muss deswegen auch wenn wir es
jetzt ermöglichen sich wieder mit
innerhalb der familie mit mehr menschen
zu treffen
es ist trotzdem wichtig dass man diese
eineinhalb meter abstand weiter im kopf
hat und dass man hier eben wenn dort
draußen sind da wo man eben diesen
abstand nicht halten kann
beim einkaufen sei es im
personennahverkehr das dann entsprechend
die masken die nase mund bedeckung auch
getragen wird auch in dem was wir an der
schule mit angedacht haben was im
gastronomiebereich dann auch angedacht
dass der ministerpräsident hat ja schon
etliches hierzu auch erzählt und erklärt
das ist das wo wir eben auch sehr stark
weiter auf diesen schutz achten werden
die zahlen uns täglich anschauen werden
es kann auch mal schwankungen geben das
sollte uns dann nicht gleich aus der
ruhe bringen
aber es geht darum immer denn gentzen
klar zu beobachten und regional und
lokal die bereiche anzugehen und dort
dann vor ort zu überlegen was müssen für
besondere maßnahmen vielleicht ergriffen
werden und das dann auch umzusetzen und
das wird das sein wo wir in den nächsten
wochen ganz hart daran arbeiten werden
vielen herzlichen dank aber noch einmal
an alle die bisher so mitgewirkt haben
sonst wäre der heutige schritt nicht
möglich dankeschön
wir kommen zu ihren fragen haben bereits
acht meldungen ich würde sie bitten alle
immer auch im interesse der kollegen
sich auf maximal zwei fragen zu
beschränken
wir beginnen mit vielen vom hörfunk des
bayerischen rundfunks
aber sie haben sehr früh und dann immer
wieder lockerungen und eine exit
strategie gefordert haben sie sich
durchgesetzt
meine frage an sie und herr söder es
gibt erste studien wonach frauen jetzt
die arbeitszeit reduziert haben und auch
das so lange machen solange das nicht
wieder voll läuft die organisiert
befürchten sie da einen rückschritt in
die alte rollenverteilung
na ja wir haben wochenlang diskutiert
was denn der richtige zeitpunkt sei
ich glaube dass uns im ergebnis gar
nicht verschieden aufgestellt hatten
vielleicht hätte man zwei wochen eher
oder eine woche eher sorgen können aber
nicht unbedingt sagen müssen es waren
einfach nur die unwägbarkeiten sehr groß
aber ich bin jetzt mit diesem ergebnis
sehr zufrieden natürlich will der
hotelier natürlich will der gastwirt der
restaurantbesitzer wissen wann muss er
war einkaufen waren muss er personal
einstellen usw
aber mit diesem zeitplan können wir
jetzt sehr gut leben und achtzehnten
geht's los in der gastronomie ich will
jetzt das nicht wer hat sich
durchgesetzt sondern dies ist ein
gemeinsam gutes ergebnis wofür ich ja
dem koalitionspartner die
ministerpräsidentin personen besonders
danke zum einen würde man sagen das was
wir machen die sind einfach nicht lumpen
öffnung sondern es ist ein modell die
letzten wochen bestand für mich immer
ein bisschen die schwierigkeit auch bei
den einzelnen konferenzen einige einige
medien haben das ja dann auch
geschrieben die zugang hatten zu den
inneren besprechungen dass das so
stückwerk war hier ein bolzplatz daran
museum und das der große die strategie
dahinter nicht so erkennbar war
und zwar wichtig deswegen haben wir auch
nachdem etliche kollegen einfach für
sich entschieden haben was völlig
legitim ist ein eine stelle oder eine
teilweise öffnung zu machen und wir uns
entschieden einen langfristigen in sich
geschlossenen plan vorzulegen
also die in sicht geschlossenheit können
sie an den zeitachsen sehen alles später
als alle vorgenannten bereichen auch
alles weniger wenn sie sehen wo anders
in sachsen anhalt geht man von fünf
kontaktpersonen bei uns bleibt ist der
einfluss der familie beispielsweise und
wir haben wenn sie dieses mit schulen
kitas ansehen nicht einfach irgendwie
alle ist in die schule oder nichts
sondern werden wir diesen 50 50 ein sehr
behutsamen weg mit vielen vielen
angeboten sehr flexiblen möglichkeiten
die wir haben
regional unterschiedlich zu gewichten
wir glauben dass es für bayern ein
passgenaues konzeptes für die nächsten
wochen bis pfingsten und wir glauben
auch dass es für die die besonders
vorsichtig erklären wollen
und das zum maßstab machen sogar eine
blaupause sein kann nicht sein muss so
bei der gastronomie glaube ich ist der
25 für die speiselokale ist jeder
überwiegende teil nun die hotels der
zeitrahmen in denen wir immer genannt
hatten
wir werden sehen aber im achtzehnten ist
mit der außengastronomie funktioniert
ist die blaupause auch dafür klappt so
das klappt es nicht
ich sage ihnen jetzt schon voraus die
gene konzepte werden sportliche sache
sportlichste ist in der gastronomie und
es muss ich dann auch bewähren im alltag
allerdings sind alle guten willens das
weiß ich und das ist das wichtige und
das ist glaube ich ist der gute wille
eines aber muss in der umsetzung
funktionieren
und ich hoffe übrigens auch sehr haben
sie zum beispiel versammlungsrecht
ansehen dass man eindruck dass viele die
die positiven entwicklungen nicht
wahrnehmen wollen sondern bewusst eine
art von provokation machen wenn ich
manche der demonstrationen sie die waren
mit welchen plakaten von ganz rechts
außen von ganz linksaußen angriffe zb
auf die heute schon ähnliches mehr
da muss ich sagen bin nach wie vor der
überzeugung nicht alle haben die
vernunft der letzten morgen auf sich
selber übertragen
deswegen wird der staat auch wachsam
bleiben in jeder beziehung also ist das
erste das zweite die diskussion gab es
über eine wild quasi auch ein bisschen
die sich so nicht
also zum einen einmal ist es so dass
mein eindruck ist dass viele
partnerschaften sich das auch
partnerschaftlich organisiert haben
dass es heute nicht automatisch körper
in jungen paaren wenn wir reden über
kinderbetreuung es so ist dass die
gehalts verteilung so ist wie sie früher
mal war heute in der regel entweder
gleiche einkommen viele frauen haben zum
teil ein besseres einkommen
das hängt auch von der branche jeweils
ab in der die sind die die die familien
mein eindruck ist die haben wir sehr gut
organisiert und wenn ich die jungen
mädchen und jungen frau in serie zu tage
die haben da ihre klare auffassung vom
leben und unterstützen wir auch sehr und
deswegen glaube ich diese art von
rückschritt glaube ich nicht ich glaube
er noch was anderes was wichtig ist
ich finde schon dass wir jetzt aus
dieser krise nicht einfach wieder an den
status quo von vorher zurückkehren
sollen
ich finde es sind viele sachen auch
geschehen uns aufgefallen die positiv
waren also home office bedeutete nicht
heim an den herd
home office ist eine form von work life
balance auch möglicherweise ist eine
form von besserer organisation
vielleicht sogar von familie und beruf
deswegen sollte man auch die positiven
seiten heraus ziehen die
weiterentwickeln
deswegen werden wir mit hochdruck daran
arbeiten der kultusminister ist da wild
entschlossen wenn ich das sagen darf die
digitalisierung ideen in der schule und
das geld ist da vorliegt so schnell wie
möglich weiter umzusetzen
ich glaube dass das auf dauer ein
spannendes ergänzungsangebot zur schule
sein kann
und wenn ich das bei meinen kindern
sehen kann dass der eindruck dass das
was über das digitale lernen erfolgt zum
teil mindestens genauso anspruchsvoll
sein kann wie das im anderen fall ist
deswegen glaube ich sollten wir die
vorteile nutzen und das gilt übrigens
wenn ich den satz ergänzen auf auch im
bereich der wirtschaft ich glaube wir
brauchen jetzt nicht einfach einen reset
knopf nach dem motto klimaschutz gibson
und und und wer lange nichts daraus also
ich persönlich fand es schon
bemerkenswert wie regenerationsphasen in
der ökologie stadt posen haben dass in
bestimmten häfen sich wird der
mittelmeer tiere am finde ich es vorher
nie gegeben hat wir sollten einfach zur
seite wischen also nicht nach dem motto
jetzt wird wieder in die hände gespuckt
wir steigern nur das bruttosozialprodukt
sondern dass qualifizierte wirtschaften
das intelligente wirtschaften das
technologische wirtschaften
voranzubringen
deswegen zum beispiel beim autohändler
aus hubert sagte eindeutig dass wir
technologie prämien brauchen an der
stelle um werte co2 bei stickoxiden zu
verbessern
also ich glaube wir sollten nicht das
verlernen was wir aus dieser krise
erlernt haben
dann hätte nämlich diese krise neben
aller betroffenheit und einschränkung
auch an den lehrreichen sind das
nächstes christina lowinski sat 1 welt
ev
freilich ins gerade nicht auf dem platz
dann sind wir vor uli bachmeier
augsburger allgemeine
ja ich habe zwei fragen zum einen bitte
zur autoindustrie dass man da helfen
muss das ist möglicherweise einsichtig
was viele menschen nicht verstehen wenn
man das nicht an bedingungen knüpft also
wenn zum beispiel jetzt geholfen wird
und dann trotzdem hohe dividenden und
boni gezahlt werden was ist ihre
überlegung da und dann eine ganz
konkrete frage über freibäder ist noch
gar nicht nachgedacht also gibt es da
perspektive also freibäder ist so vor
juni gar nichts weil da einfach die
infektionsgefahr zu hoch ist wir werden
ja die sie wissen wir werden auch wieder
mit der ende mai weitere bilanz ziehen
und dann schauen was weitergeht da gibt
es noch andere bereiche über die man
reden muss aber das ist jetzt mal für
den michael perspektive und beim auto
sage ich folgendes also wenn winfried
kretschmann und nicht da einer meinung
sind als grüner und als schwarzer
kollege weil sowieso
man muss ja etwas dahinter stehen also
keine ideologische sondern eine tief
pragmatische frage wir glauben schon
dass am automobil auch das bayerische
das bayerische industrielle herz hängt
wir brauchen in kurzfristigen impuls
denn die internationalen märkte werden
das naturbad ja zurecht angesprochen
sehr zeitversetzt ansehen
das heißt überliefert strukturen das
heißt wer merkt also müssen wir
schneller ein impuls setzen
deswegen muss eine zeitlich begrenzte
prämie für einen neuen technologie stand
glaube ich es enorm wichtig wurde ein
riesen schub bringen können
technologisch ökologisch aber auch
industriell so dass ich glaube ist die
frage dass man es macht auf jeden fall
sinnvoll auch mit so einer recycling
ich bin beim thema boni und dividenden
etwas geteilt weil dividende betrifft
nämlich nicht nur bachmeier
großaktionäre sondern die ganz vielen
vielen kleinen linien kleinen depot
klein pro folio eben das haben die
würde nahezu eine enteignung viele viele
kleine aktionäre sie kennen die
schutzgemeinschaft der kleinaktionäre
vieler kleinanleger die sich dessen
wünschen was die boni betrifft kann ich
nur sagen das bayerische kabinett hat
heute nochmal die nullrunde rechtlich
umgesetzt
ich finde in diesen zeiten haben so
viele mit nullrunden zu leben ich finde
da dürfen sich viele ein beispiel daran
nehmen vielleicht nur 350.000 menschen
in der kurzarbeit die in der autobranche
tätig sind 350.000 schnell wieder
herausholen und in die vollbeschäftigung
bringen also besser und die zulieferer
sind ja auch alle dabei der frage war
dieser bedingung ist wir werden sehen
was also das glaube ich das glaube ich
rechtlich ist das nicht machbar
ich glaube das wäre ein gutes signal wir
werden jetzt das so entscheiden wir
brauchen dringend eine schnelle
entscheidung darüber denn wenn das jetzt
wochen und monate dauert über solche
entscheidung dann wird gar nichts mehr
gekauft weil die einen warten auf die
prämien und die anderen halten sich
zurück mit mit einer entscheidung von
aktuellen autokauf also wenn das macht
schnell
ich glaube es ist auch gut wir haben
jetzt die ganzen reihe waren es
angesprochen die ganzen überbrückungs
programme also soforthilfen und
darlehens sachen da müssen wir schauen
dass sie schneller bearbeitet wird ist
zum teil noch an der kapazitätsgrenze
und dann kommen die durch start
programme die müssen wir dann jetzt im
mai auf jeden fall diskutieren was
nächstes andreas ob rtl n tv ein sogar
eine frage nur zur
entscheidungsgrundlage haben sie ja
gesagt es sind die zahlen jetzt würde
mich interessieren der umgedrehte weg
haben sie für sich zahlen festgelegt ab
wann man lockerungen wieder zurücknehmen
müsste aus dem kanzleramt es zum
beispiel zu hören dass wenn in einem
landkreis innerhalb einer woche mehr als
35 neuinfektionen auf 100000 einwohner
aufkommen müssen zum beispiel wieder
einschränkungen entstehen haben sie da
konkrete zahlen die sie zurate oder
annehmen also wir haben zunächst mal die
ganzen kennzahlen genommen in der
letzten wochen in der relation und wenn
sie anschauen wie haben jetzt 13
millionen einwohner 6400 aktuell
infizierte
das sind 0,05 prozent sogar ein 0,04 19
wenn sie die relation setzen dann müssen
sie die angemessenheit sehen und da die
exponentielle wachstum völlig weg es ist
also sinkt die zahl der infektionen
sinkt und zwar deutlich innerhalb einer
woche praktisch halbiert glaube ich ist
das verlässliche basis die andere zahl
darüber diskutieren wir gerade mit dem
kanzleramt und auch von mr
was ist der richtige weg deswegen sind
wir auch der festen überzeugung regional
werben erst machen wobei ganz
entscheidendes zu erkennen die regionale
situation also es ist jetzt spezielle
altenheime die die infektion gerade
ausmachen ist das flächendeckend oder
nicht deswegen habe ich auch sagte der
regionale differenzierung ist extrem
wichtig wir gehen jetzt so vor dass an
den stellen wo wir noch mehr infektion
haben also höhere haben wobei auch da
überall in allen hotspots geht's runter
wo wir die haben jetzt noch mal unsere
power ein an der stelle also die power
die wir woanders nimmer brauchen wir im
landkreis etwas gar nichts mehr
jetzt mir dann bewusst ein am personal
an material an schutzausrüstungen um
dort sozusagen die letzten keime auch zu
isolieren und deswegen ist das
appartement weil wenn irgendwo mal
wieder was auf land wären zum beispiel
wenn sie ihnen könnte schon heute was
sie eine schwierige situation war und
was immer vor ort wirklich sehr gut
gemeistert hat
da gab es auch vor ort den wunsch
schnell abzuwickeln schnell gerade
antenne zu machen melanie das haben wir
gemeinsam entschieden so konnte dort die
infektion in die gesamte entwicklung
verhindert werden wenn sie noch mal
denken dass wir zum beispiel ja sehr
starken aus ist beeinflusst waren wir
hatten im landkreis freising ich glaube
einer der am karneval war es kam nie
hundertprozentig beweisen noch kein wurf
der hat aber in freising zum richtigen
cluster geführt da können sie sehen dass
die schnelle reagieren wichtig ist dann
glaube ich ist in zukunft wichtig nicht
überall das runter zu fahren sondern
dort wo die gefahr entsprechend
erkennbar ist und letztlich eine
ergänzung
das grundproblem weil diesem corona
phänomen ist
das planungssicherheit so schwer ist wie
können sie genau sagen mama spielen
zahlen ineinander eine rolle
das sind bin ich auch dagegen
wissenschaftler zu beschimpfen
natürlich wünscht man sich als politiker
dass es eine zahl gibt ich glaube ihnen
geht es da ähnlich wie mir eine zahl an
die kann man sich festhalten es war aber
wir lernen jeden tag neues jeden tag
egal welcher wissenschaftlich erkennen
hat mir neue studie gesehen
es werden glaube ich habe sagt 80
studien veröffentlicht 80 weltweit
aber es ergibt sich jeden tag eine
unterschiedliche entwicklung und
deswegen ist das natürlich ein stück
weit auch sichtbar durch durch
entwickeln an der stelle
es ist nicht leicht aber die zahlen die
wir jetzt haben halt meine für eine sehr
verlässliche basis tun habe ich auch
verständnis wenn andere bundesländer
habe mecklenburg-vorpommern er die kaum
zahlen haben jetzt auch sonder gema
einen schritt schneller
darum sagen wir ja man kann mit
unterschiedlichen geschwindigkeiten
arbeiten
es gibt den schnellen weg und es gibt
den vorsichtigeren regeln wir glauben
auch schon unsere zahlen der
vorsichtigere einfach der bessere ist
denn wir wollen einfach nur sicher gehen
da ist dann auch unterschiedlich bei uns
der einer der möchte es keine stelle
haben aus seiner sicht heraus ich habe
merck sei das große kann sie muss
stimmen und das geheimnis bei alexander
kain passauer neue presse
direkt dazu also die objektiven werte
für die atmen der strategie sind noch
nicht festgelegt dass per kanzleramt er
arbeitet wenn ich es richtig verstand
bleiben sie ist eine empfehlung es wird
eine empfehlung sein denn die maßgabe
wie's geht kann er ohnehin wie das land
treffen schauen sie das ist ja die
grundproblematik eigentlich in der
rechtlichen situation in der wir stehen
der bund und ich bin der bundeskanzler
gesagt auch persönlich sehr dankbar für
ihren sehr umsichtigen kostet uns ja
auch stützt an der an der stelle mit
echtes dann auch entsprechend auch ein
kontakt und haben es miteinander
gesprochen und und ausgetauscht der bund
selber hat de facto kaum eine rechtliche
möglichkeit rechtlich können nur die
länder entscheiden so ist das
infektionsschutzgesetz aber keine
empfehlungen versuchen
und wir hatten ihnen da da wird jetzt
über zahlen geredet empfehle ohne
geredet die man dann anwenden kann oder
nicht aber sie sind natürlich schon eine
orientierungs maßstab 1 durch jetzt zu
meiner eigentlichen frage sie wollen ja
auch regionalisieren
wie lässt sich das rechtlich
bewerkstelligen moment machen sie eine
verfügung die gilt für bayern gibt es
dann in zukunft unter verfügungen für
irgendwelche landkreise oder regionen
es ist auch jetzt schon möglich dass ja
die gesundheitsämter locker noch
entscheidungen treffen und wir haben
immer wieder auch in die im
rechtsverordnung mit aufgenommen das ist
ja auch abweichungen geben kann
für eben vor ort von den
kreisverwaltungsbehörden sie haben es
wärmt das beispiel von gehört von
tirschenreuth wo man dann ja gesagt hat
dass nur zum beispiel diesen ort schon
frühzeitiger auch wirklich eine ausgangs
beschränkungen damals aufgelegt hat sie
erinnern sich vielleicht in straubing
was gewesen wo man im bereich der masken
frühzeitige auch von der verpflichtung
gesprochen hat also die gesundheitsämter
vor ort und die kreisverwaltungsbehörden
haben eben hier die möglichkeiten auch
lokal reagieren zu können und maßnahmen
entsprechend aussprechen zu können und
eben dann auch verfügungen auf den weg
bringen zu können
für uns ist es schon wichtig dass wir
bayernweit ein gemeinsames vorgehen
haben
aber es ist eben auch notwendig da ich
brauche dann vielleicht eben nicht mehr
für ganz bayern irgendeine regelung
wieder zurückdrehen sondern kann sagen
okay lokal vor ort merke ich dass die
menschen vielleicht das eine oder andere
eben nicht in der verantwortung
wahrgenommen haben oder dass ich noch
einmal genauer mit testungen reingehe
wenn ich im endeffekt geschehen dort im
erleben sind die pflegekräfte in den
heimen mit betroffenen ja oder nein die
vielleicht selber noch kaum symptome
verspüren um eben frühzeitig das
unterbrechen zu können dass es nicht
auch auf die bewohner übergeht
und so stellen wir uns das eben vor
deswegen brauchen wir immer dann
besonders
testung material kräfte die sozusagen
mit helfen da wo eben die zahlen nach
oben gehen und dass das ist der weg den
wir dafür lokale ausbruchsgeschehen auch
gehen wollen
da wenn eine partnerschaft des
entscheidend 5 also wir machen das nicht
von oben herab sondern partnerschaftlich
mit lampre mit oberbürgermeistern wir
haben zwar viele der sachen die mit
münchen betreffen auch heute noch mal
die strategie gab es für einen austausch
noch mal was sagte oberbürgermeister
sowie für praktikabel hält er das ganze
was sagt der landrat dazu wie muss man
dagegen partnerschaftlich also das ist
nicht von oben herab
das hat sich bewährt deswegen sage ich
auch noch mal ausdrücklich auch wenn
natürlich jetzt im landtag wird eine
neue lebendigkeit herrscht was gutes für
die demokratie auch da trotzdem noch mal
danke für die schwierigsten phasen hat
die bayerische demokratie auch sehr gut
agiert und sie können an viele der
vorschläge sehen die auch weg gemacht
haben da gab es sehr gute ideen aus der
opposition die haben dann aufgegriffen
und umgesetzt
mal vergeben dass das in so einer
situation mehr als angemessen ist zwei
kurze frage fitnessstudios die freibäder
oder aber perspektive im sommer es
vorhanden es viel besser wird es hängt
ja auch vieles davon ab wie die weiteren
zahlen sind
es hängt vieles davon ab
wie die weitere medikamenten und
infusionen sich ergibt ich höre da
völlig unterschiedlich ist die einen
denken an zwei jahre an das kann viel
schneller noch in diesem jahr passieren
da kann ich nichts dazu sagen
auch das ist natürlich ein maßstab dann
wenn sie beispielsweise nimmt
möglichkeit haben oder ein sehr
wirksames medikament haben
dann hilft es dass ich wollte damals ja
auch wenn die zahlen jetzt weiter
runtergehen bauen wir umgekehrt die
medizin kapazitäten auf wir haben noch
mal einen kompletten notfallplan in der
tasche sozusagen also wir haben ja auch
den totalen ernstfall geprobt das ist
wir haben noch für die nächsten jahre
und für die denkbare zweite welle wenn
sie vielleicht käme oder im herbst
kommen könnte dass die gefahr übrigens
am größten haben wir komplett von
krankenhäusern notfall krankenhäusern
versorgungs plänen von verlegung plänen
haben wir jetzt komplett alles in der
tasche da ist muss ich wirklich sagen
das ist eine große leistung dass das in
diesen drei wochen hochfahren es gut
geklappt hat christian deutschländer
münchner merkur personalfrage zum
tourismus sie sprechen von einer
möglichen öffnung
ende mai soll ich jetzt meinen
pfingsturlaub buchen soll ich lieber zu
hause bleiben und sind auch gäste aus
anderen bundesländern in bayern
willkommen also das erste aldi
grenzöffnungen an der stelle ist muss
der bund entscheiden
der bund hat horst seehofer meine volle
unterstützung für einen sehr
vorsichtigen kurs volle unterstützung da
sie in bayern urlaub machen können und
als redakteur des münchner merkurs halte
ich sogar für zwingend dass sie in
bayern urlaub machen sollten und sie
können sich können auch woanders machen
das geplante tolle gegen den ja sie
müssen auch nicht in südbayern machen
sie können auch zum beispiel in franken
wird wird es sicherlich auch mal noch
das bewusstsein noch mal deutlich
verstärken und erweitern also in bayern
können sie dann urlaub machen allerdings
halten unter bedingungen die sind das
heißt zum beispiel die bedingungen die
für die gastro gegen gelten natürlich
dann auch für die hotellerie
was jetzt den gastronomischen bereich im
hotellerie bereich betrifft wenn sie
eine ferienwohnung haben sie können auch
kempten in bayern
auch da gibt es hervorragend
ich kann also so wie wir es jetzt zurück
sagt die kanzlerin und wir gemeinsam
alle wir sind sie vor einigen wochen
haben viele gesagt und uns zugerufen
holt uns heim
das hat mich sehr bewegt sich bis heute
das ist eine große leistung auch das
außenministers fand das organisiert sein
muss immer wirklich auch darum ein lob
an alle verteilen
jetzt sind alle da jetzt kann man auch
mal eine zeit lang bleiben und den
urlaub pfingsten mal so genießen die in
bayern ist wir haben jetzt noch
insgesamt fünf fragen ich würde dann
auch die runde schließen auch diesen
fünf fragen als nächstes julian von
löwis bei shell rundfunk ich habe eine
frage an frau hummel herrn söder und ein
halber jeweils ganz kurz frau mit sind
regelmäßige tests in pflegeeinrichtungen
geplant also tests für pflegende
pflegepersonal corona tests die
möglicherweise regelmäßig durchgeführt
werden
herr söder morgen in der schaltkonferenz
mit der kanzlerin geht es darum eine
entscheidung bezüglich fußball und
geisterspielen in den profi ligen und
herr aiwanger verstehe ich es richtig
dass die wirtschaften die biergärten
öffnen aber man wenn man nicht mit der
eigenen familie erster linie hin geht
nur mit einer kontaktperson hingehen
kann
in österreich sind so glaube ich vier
erwachsene wenn ich mich nicht irre die
an einem tisch erlaubt sind wenn ich
beginnen darf ich hier mit einem
stufenkonzept vorangehen das heißt da wo
erkrankungen sind die werden als erstes
natürlich mit rein testungen mich hier
nachgeschaut
wer ist alles betroffen wie bereits
jetzt ja vielfach schon durchgeführt und
zum zweiten dann dort wo eben so
genannte hotspots regionen sind und dann
eben immer im je nachdem wie viel
kapazitäten da sind das dann auch weiter
ausweiten
aber in diesem abgestuften verfahren wo
betroffenheit ist wo betroffenheit droht
wenn ich das so sagen darf wenn
drumherum schon viel infekt geschehen
ist ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass dort
was geschehen kann
auch gross dann hier und dann eben auch
je nach kapazitäten eben auch im
weiteren dann wie wird man im gasthaus
oder im biergarten sitzen das müssen wir
im letzten detail noch festzurren aber
neue liegen die ist eben die lösung eine
familie am tisch oder bis zu zwei leute
die eben dann entsprechend weit
auseinander setzen müssten man kann sie
kann sich vorstellen dass man vielleicht
dem biertisch der eine an der einen ecke
unter anderem auf den seiten gegenüber
unter anderen ecke dann könnten in
meinen augen wahrscheinlich auch zwei
fremde an einem tisch sitzen das müssen
wir im detail jetzt noch klären will
jetzt noch nicht festgestellt haben
und ich glaube ja dass viele gastronomen
den weg gehen werden wie es eben viele
restaurants jetzt auch schon hatten im
außenbereich dass man kleine tische hat
wo eben nur einer sitzt es werden sehr
viele leute alleine kommen und wollen
auch alleine oder in einem eigenen tisch
sitzen und nicht mit einem fremden
gesichtern gesicht mit 150 abstand
sondern es werden sehr viele auf der
insel tische gehen oder eben maximal
zwei an einem tisch sind jetzt die
konzepte die werden aber noch
rechtzeitig verkündet über fußball wird
sicher gebildet
patricia schäfer funktioniert bitte den
knopf drücken gedrückt halten
was ein bisschen erledigt ich wollte
auch einmal fragen wie es mit dem
abstand in den biergärten des opfers die
gastronomen dann selbst kontrollieren
müssen und zur grenzöffnung eventuell
österreich hatte sie sagen also das ist
vom infektionsgeschehen abhängt
österreich hat sehr niedrige
infektionsraten in nordrhein westfalen
sind die grenzen zu den niederlanden
offen
bei uns nach wie vor strengen
geschlossen sie sagen sie sind zu einem
vorsichtigen kurs da wieder weiter
verfahren wird ja bleibt dabei
vorsichtig august die letzte
entscheidung liegt beim bund
bundesinnenminister und der sonne artig
an der stelle so unterstütze und das
zweite normal also wir werden das sehr
streng kontrollieren ob dies eingehalten
wird
das ist alles keine kein kavaliersdelikt
an der stelle
also da gibt es dann auch eine
ordnungswidrigkeit strafen so und da ist
jeder selbst herr seines verfahrens und
wer mehrfach dagegen verstoßen sollte
der muss damit rechnen dass er das halt
nicht ewig machen kann
dafür gibt es die sogenannte
zuverlässigkeit nach der gewerbeordnung
aber das müssen dann die die entsprechen
ordnungsämter beurteilen schauen sie das
ist wie im fußball
da macht die liga hervorragende konzepte
und da gibt es einzelne spieler wie
jetzt zu lesen war
die sich sehr sehr sehr unglücklich
verhalten findet auch gut dass dann
solche profivereine sehr hart dagegen
entscheiden weil das bringt das ganze
konzept in verruf und so bild ist war
dann auch wir waren bisher genau
überwachen
die zuständigen fachminister übrigens
werden in den nächsten wochen primär die
dinge verfolgen das heißt auch jetzt was
pressekonferenzen betrifft primär jetzt
wieder die fachminister in der
pressekonferenz
auch hier war jetzt sind wir sozusagen
eine umsetzungsphase dessen für die
nächsten wochen
und da wird jeder darauf schauen dass
das verwaltungstechnische
organisiert wird das wird evaluiert
woche für woche hart im ard
politikmagazin kontraste ja auch eine
frage an den ministerpräsidenten
sie haben sich auch gerade häufiger
distanziert von dem vorgehen anderer
bundesländer im föderalismus
insbesondere nrw sie haben mal gesagt
beim urlaub gehört auch der westen nicht
dazu das bayerische vorgehen die
vorsicht sei besser als ein
übersteigertes vorgehen sie haben gerade
auch kritisiert die beschimpfung von
virologen deswegen ministerpräsident
eine frage von kontraste beschädigen sie
nicht armin laschet mit solchen spitzen
bemerkungen im rennen um den cdu vorsitz
aber wir haben schon den eindruck dass
die rivalität zunehmend raum einnimmt
auch persönlich wenn man sich ihre
bemerkungen wirklich systematisch
durchliest deswegen noch mal eine frage
geht in dieser realität geht in diese
rivalität zunehmend auf den nerv oder
finden sie zunehmend gefallen daran was
nein kein gefallen oder kein darf sie
stehen ja in der öffentlichen als
protagonisten dafür eine sachliche
auseinandersetzung für einen
unterschiedlichen kurs den haben sie
heute auch dargelegt und persönlich
interessiert aber natürlich auch es
fallen spitzen es wird ja auch eine eine
öffentlichkeitsarbeit gemacht in eigener
sache
und wie wirkt sich das aus genau halb
der union wäre die frage also ich bin
für bayern zuständig ich erfülle meinen
amtseid und jeder ministerpräsident
leistet großartiges an seiner stelle
es ist natürlich ihre zulässige
aufgabe eine aufgabe sehr nett aber ihre
natürlich möglichkeit die dinge zu sehen
wie sie das für richtig halten
das ist natürlich klar aber ich sehe da
keinerlei probleme oder schwierigkeiten
jeder ministerpräsident gibt sich mühe
nach bestem wissen und gewissen seinen
job zu tun
jeder ist sein land verpflichtet sei am
landtag unseren bürgerinnen bürger und
jeder macht einen guten job und jeder
arbeitet gut zusammen nehmen wir jetzt
mal an die cdu findet keinen kandidaten
würden sie dann für eine kandidatur
union leitstelle ich werde nicht dass
cdu vorsitzender kandidieren
das kann in hohenheim ich versprechen
landesligist kanzlerkandidat die vierte
frage ich glaube jetzt kommen wir dann
auch die kollegen wieder zu wort als
nächstes christoph trost für dpa mit dem
das würde zwei fragen deutschland ist
jetzt entwickelt teppich in corona exit
prescht dabei jetzt ja auch vor oder
zumindest mit
wozu braucht sind die mpk morgen noch
braut sieht darüber hinaus noch
sozusagen wenn jedes land ohnehin selber
entscheidet vielleicht auch entscheiden
muss die zweite frage nochmal zur
forderung des bundes nach diesem
automatismus sie sagen da ist jedes land
selber zuständig würden sie für bayern
sondern automatismus einsetzen dass
lockerung zurückgenommen werden müssen
regional wende bestimmte zahl von
neuinfektionen beispielsweise pro 100000
einwohner überschritten wird und wo läge
diese zahl ich habe gott gewesen aus
einer zeitung wird zitiert ist soll in
einer besprechung des gesagten sein
dazu können auch nicht stellung nehmen
also ich weiß war die frage wie vorhin
gekommen ist wir haben nochmal die dpa
nachgelesen
das soll aus einer zeitung seine
internen schalte berichtet worden sein
das heißt wir waren neun mal sehen wie
jetzt dann die weitere entwicklung ist
wir werden uns das genau anschauen
man muss dabei vor allem eines sehen man
muss auch sehen wie die entwicklung ist
bei einer entsprechenden zahl ist
steigend ist fallend wenn eine
entwicklung deutlich fallend ist anders
zu bewerten als wenn sie steigen ist ich
glaube schon dass es sinnvoll spezielle
pandemie pläne zu machen
ich habe das vorher schon angesprochen
das waren wir dann auch tun wobei die
bei uns zuständigen land oder den
oberbürgermeister in den betroffenen
gebieten eine außerordentlich großartige
arbeit
also noch immer wirklich sagen was da in
einigen sogenannten hot spots die
letzten wochen gemacht wurde
wir haben wir zum beispiel deswegen
werden erinnert sich rosenheim und
straubing das vorziehen der masken
pflichtbewusst auch erlaubt oder
empfohlen weil sie gesagt dann bei uns
ist die infektionsrate höhe
wahrscheinlich auch entsprechende
auswirkungen zu geben positiven das
heißt wir werden uns da noch einmal
genau überlegen welche zahl wir für
angemessen halten auch bei uns auch eine
abstimmung natürlich und dann an den
entsprechenden zahlen orientieren mit
speziellen regionalen pandemieplänen ich
glaube der pandemieplan ist das
entscheidende
und da kann es auch zu verschiebungen
der lockerungen kommen wenn in einer
situation ist noch nicht der fall ist
ganz klar ja das muss man einfach sehen
die frage ist nämlich dann aber auch
noch wo ist das infektionsgeschehen
allgemein verteilt speziell in einer
bestimmten situation kann es analysiert
und lokalisiert werden
und morgen glaube ich ist der austausch
einfach generell wichtig weil wir
unabhängig davon was jetzt in jedem
einzelfall ist hier noch über eine reihe
von anderen fragen reden werden
wir werden über das thema
großveranstaltung und reden wie
definiert sich das auf dauer
wir werden auch nur weil das thema
kultur reden beispielsweise wie geht es
beim thema kultur weiter also es gibt
schon eine reife und fragen und
entspannter weise vielleicht gibt es
auch die eine zusätzliche sehr gute idee
was bei kitas und schulen noch gemacht
werden kann auch wenn unser
kultusminister unsere sozialminister auf
der basis der beschlüsse der jeweiligen
fachminister konferenzen auf sich
entwickelt wird die anschlussfrage noch
das format morgen wird es dann weiter
auch alle zwei wochen so war es zuletzt
zweimal wöchentlich bestand haben oder
ist das absehbar morgen der letzte die
letzte runde dieser art also sie ist
niemals die letzte ministerien konferenz
mit der kanzlerin das muss man jetzt die
nächsten tage und wochen sehen wie es
sich entwickelt
aber ich halte es für jeden fall
sinnvoll in gesprächen zu sein und für
die meisten ist es kein problem eine
video-konferenz und der zuweilen sogar
die medien zugeschaltet werden lässt
sich ja immer sehr schnell organisieren
zum abschluss fliese schnell süddeutsche
zeitung
ich würde direkt anschließen wir haben
gestern noch gesagt die vorschläge von
anderen ländern haben sie etwas
unglücklich genannt wie unterscheidet
sich jetzt hier die beschlüsse von von
bayern einen tag vorher davon was damals
eigentlich die letzten eineinhalb
stunden gemacht forschen mal genau
erklärt was der unterschied ist zwischen
dem einen modell und dem anderen modell
wir müssen doch folgendes wir hatten
letzte woche bei der mpk eigentlich
vereinbart gehabt
ich habe letzte woche schon dafür
plädiert für grundlegende dinge ich habe
auch den termin letzte woche skeptisch
gesehen ähnlich wie die bundeskanzlei
hätten es besser gefunden wenn der woche
noch gewartet um zahlen abzuwarten
und wir haben dann sehr im detail und
diskutiert und detail diskutiert uns
fehlte ein bisschen die große linie
jetzt haben etliche bundesländer und
zwar eine stunde der nach bereits
entscheidung getroffen also dass die
kanzlerin ich aus der pressekonferenz
gekommen waren unglaublich 78 dpa
meldungen was das bundesland anders
macht und das zum teil ohne dass vorher
zu kommunizieren
sachsen anhalt war einmal sehr deutlich
jetzt auch mecklenburg vorpommern
niedersachsen und andere zum teil auch
das ist in ordnung wenn gerichte einen
zu einer entscheidung zwingen
und wir glauben mit seinem fiat minister
noch einmal lange mit anderen besprochen
wir glauben einfach dass es sinnvoll ist
ein modell zu zeigen die bayern erwarten
sich jetzt auch ein vorschlag das ist
ein weg den range vereinbart eine range
eine bandbreite von schnelleren
maßnahmen oder von den umsichtigen aus
unserer sicht oder langsam rein und da
kann man halt zu dem zweiten teil
so wird sich sozusagen die die range
etwas definiert aber was wir heute
machen ist einfach den plan für bayern
vorstellen
und vielleicht inspiriertes den ein oder
anderen zusätzlich ein danke tiriac darf
ich ganz fremd
das unglücklich dass dann auf wasser das
dann bezogen auf die inhalte oder daran
sich zu gehen und glücklich aber zum
beispiel so dass bei sachsen anhalt ist
sehr weitreichend gewesen weil wenn sie
jetzt mal anschauen die frage ob sie 800
quadratmeter nehmen oder nicht das war
nicht das herzstück der strategie das
herzstück der strategie ist die frage
der kontakt distanzierung wenn ich das
aufgebe ist alles andere im grunde
genommen bricht in sich zusammen also
das ist das herzstück des ganzen
weil es das einzige wirksame instrument
gegen korona ist jedenfalls im moment
dann danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Musik]